ці кадри пожирала російської ФСБ
у спецслужби заявили про за 3 травня на
території вона косово нога Росії та
криму групи українських диверсантів столітті
як плану вали теракти на пиво
острові
реакція до нього на ізобари лася ланкою
дуже а там вид кинув і
чорба, що заявили, провокація кремля
прокоментувала ситуацію та німецькі
політики та додавши
я губи навіть вдалим щось взаємних
угланова ніж йому вірністю забав буки в
я засікав ними в конфлікті люди оджіно
ньому можна / цьому гаю основі також і
кулі тисячі наскільки конфлікту allow б
дві сторони натовпу 2у ряди сльозу ікла ти
спинну за ходом ви робот і політичні
рішення та шляхи німа
основне харчування для німецьких експертів
як ситуація розвороту то ми поставили
сильно очевидно ще крем або путін
прогнути отчины ти здогад white позов на
україну та українську навряд чи я самий
буду квіти скачається підготовку та дах
деки коментатори
даного повторно не буду подалі
ескалації конфлікту на сході України
кидається ясно мова поки не скажеш
ти скоби сам денного че не томите 10
сарп не володимир путін закинувши
український влади пари хіт до практика
терору в кімнату і чіп ідеї в криму так
вже російський лідер народжує за
зустріч нормандському форматі за дружину травня
сенсу
сам формат четвер та україна росія не
матч і на і франція ми владно сторони та
для ворога конфлікту на донбасі
схожі на кіно з нормандського формату
аджі основу частини руси такий формат
переговорив знімав без ин су краще
Путін не задував він і мінськими доглядом і
і сука я ши формат може його формат
мулан бабаків ще означати ми переговори
безпосередньо з США без участі ними чини та
Франції то поки ще голову сказати для
чого путін хоче за місяць нормально
такого формату 11 сарп не президент
україни Петра Порошенка наказавши привести
силові структури на адмін кордоні з
кримом то за все нею лінію візитівка на неї
на донбасі до пошуку та бою
області